markiplier not here with Patrick who is
now known on YouTube as Schad leech oh
hello we're here with the make-a-wish
foundation thing and his wish was to
find and meet me and also to become a
youtuber so I gave him recommendations
for all the stuff that he's going to
need to be able to start recording
videos and his channel is called Shawn
bleach and there's a link down in the
description below where you can check it
out there's no videos yet because he
hasn't got any equipment but hopefully
very soon he will be able to get that
we've just been playing video games all
day and snacking it's been an awesome
time up in Oregon here and also I didn't
mention this before but today's actually
or was my dad's birthday so I was
remarried
my dad he died a few years back and I
just hope that you know he'd be proud of
what I'm doing and I'm really happy to
be out here and be able to spend my time
happy birthday Mark's dad hanging out
with Patrick here he's awesome so check
out the channel down below and hopefully
you'll see some videos from him real
soon as soon as I get there quick note
on the equipment yeah I mean Mark's
generously provided by make-a-wish
directed yes once I get that and then I
get all I get to eat my games together
and such and decide what I want to start
out with first then they'll be my video
I'll be as usual like Mark of BO game
channel
commentator I'll try to use unique
videos not challenge videos testing
things but he's been out even told me
all of his cool ideas and I think it's
actually gonna be something really
special so check it out soon and thank
you everybody for watching and as always
we will see you in the next video bye